you wanna reduce AI fatigue
then you need to also reduce AI switching
this is very common one moment you want to code
use Cloudy Eye another moment you want to do something
you use Gemini or you use Chat GBT or you use Grok
there are just so many AI tools to use
but switching among all of these things also cause fatigue
because guess what sometimes you don't even really know
you can't remember if you have done this task from this AI
or you've done it from another one
sometimes you even spend your time looking for the content
or looking for something you've done
that you wanna continue but because you use multiple AIs
multiple files multiple everything
you find it difficult to really do
or merge some of these things that you do
so you wanna reduce fatigue
reducing the number of AI usage is very important yes
you may ask me uh
but some AI
what's better in certain field in certain things that we do
yes that's why we said if you structure what you need to do
you can really tell what to will help you but in long run
you can also ask yourself
what are you really using some of these AI to do
do you really need to switch
for somebody like me
I have about three AI's that I know I use three generative AI
one for major coding
and others for content creation and other tasks that I do
but I know when it comes to coding
it's cloud AI when it comes to maybe creative writing
I know it's chat GPT and when it comes to research
or some of the advanced writing and the likes
I know it's Gemini so I I sort of like have categorization
to what I use some of those AI to do
so when I am trying to remember anything
I know anything about writing
I won't see it in my cloud code or anything about coding
I won't see it in my Gemini you know
so when you have some of this categorization
it helps you to really streamline things down
and you don't have to really be looking for so many things
when you're not supposed to be looking for them
when it comes to AI fatigue
there are a couple of things I want you to really
really understand and remember all the time
the first is that AI should assist thinking
not replacing thinking
let us get this very clear AI should assist you in thinking
it shouldn't replace your ability to think
another thing I want us to take note of is
if AI makes you more productive
but less fulfilled
the flow is wrong you're supposed to feel more fulfilled well
you can be more productive
that's fine but the most important thing at the end of the day is
are you fulfilled we have all of this technology around us
but do you still feel fulfilled
that fulfillment is what we should be searching for
not really productivity
in other words as developers
the goal is not to write more code
the goal is to build better system without burning out
and that's how we wrap it up on this one
if you find this tip very helpful
all you need to do is follow me on all my social media platform
and again
even if you're not a developer and you have a developer friend
just ensure that you share this tip with them
so that they can also be aware of some of these things around them
thank you so much for watching this one
until next time I'll see you in the next one